Rush to Walmart or
Amazon for Force Factor.
..
>> REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS HOSTING
AROUND TABLES DEMAND
ACCOUNTABILITY AS THE BORDER
CRISIS SPIRALS OUT OF CONTROL.
>> IT IS A CRISIS THAT DIDN’T
HAVE TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS A SELF INFLICTED WOUNDS.
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS WENT TO
CENTRAL AMERICA IN SEARCH OF THE
ROOT CAUSE, SHE HAD NO FURTHER
TO GO THEN INTO THE OVAL OFFICE,
LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND REALIZE
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS THE ROOT
CAUSE.
>> WE NOW HAVE THE FIRST
PRESIDENT OF MY LIFETIME THAT
CAME INTO OFFICE AND
INTENTIONALLY UNSECURED THE
BORDER.
>> THIS IS DHS CONFIRMS
1.7 MILLION APPREHENSIONS ON THE
BORDER THIS YEAR ALONE AND THEY
HAD A SECURE BORDER, HOW MUCH
WORSE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN TO HAVE
DONALD TRUMP NOT STARTED THE
YEAR OFF AS PRESIDENT.
TOM HOME AND ATTENDED THE ROUND
TABLE AND TALKED ABOUT THAT.
A NON-HEARING HEARING.
WHERE THEY ALL YEARS YESTERDAY?
WAS ANYTHING ACCOMPLISHED
YESTERDAY?
>> THEY TOOK A LOT OF STAFF, A
LOT OF GOOD QUESTIONS, WHAT THE
GROUND LOOKED LIKE, WHAT CAUSED
THE SURGEONS HOW TO FIX IT AND
THE CHANGES THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MADE THE CAUSED
THE SURGE.
IT WAS A GOOD HEARING, VERY
INFORMATIVE.
PETE: RODNEY SCOTT WAS ASKED TO
LEAVE.
ON THE SURFACE HE SEEMS THE
ANTITHESIS OF SOMEONE WHO WILL
SECURE THE BORDER JUDGING FROM
HIS TRACK RECORD AND NOT
ADMITTING IT IS A CRISIS.
>> I THOUGHT HE SHOULD HAVE
GOTTEN HAMMERED MORE.
IF IT WERE THE TRUMP NOMINEE IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ALL OF THEM.
HE IS PRO-SANCTUARY CITIES,
REFUSED TO WORK WITH ICE,
REFUSED TO WORK WITH SPECIAL
AGENTS AND OFFICERS AND EVEN
THOUGH HIS OFFICER WANTED TO AND
THEY TRIED TO HE ORDERED THEM
NOT TO ASSIST IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES.
HE HAS RUN AGAINST DONALD TRUMP
FROM DAY ONE, SAYS HIS POLICY IS
INHUMANE, THAT DONALD TRUMP
CREATED THE MOST SECURE BORDER
IN MY LIFETIME.
THIS ADMINISTRATION, THE WORST
CHOICE, THEY WANT TO DO THEIR
JOB.
PETE: ANY DEMOCRATS UNDERSTAND
SOCIAL SECURITY POLLY --
POLITICS.
HOW TO SECURE THE BORDER, THE
PRESIDENT HAS 23% APPROVAL ON
BORDER SECURITY.
WHY WOULD IT NOT BE IN HIS
POLITICAL INTERESTS TO GET A
HOLD OF THIS THING?
>> IT ABSOLUTELY IS.
THE NUMBERS ARE AT A HISTORIC
HIGH.
WE’VE NEVER SEEN NUMBERS LIKE
THIS IN THE HISTORY OF COUNTING
NUMBERS FOR BORDER CONTROL.
IF HE CARES ABOUT THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THIS COUNTRY HE
SHOULD HAVE HEARINGS.
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION BUT PUBLIC SAFETY,
PUBLIC HEALTH.
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE.
17 PEOPLE ON THE WATCHLIST,
400,000 GOT AWAYS.
HOW MANY ARE SUSPECTED
TERRORISTS?
IF YOU THINK THE NUMBER IS 0,
YOU DON’T UNDERSTAND THE
DYNAMICS OF THE BORDER.
PETE: HE TURNED AROUND 60% OF
THE 1.7 MILLION ESPECIALLY WHEN